so Brian what is the James Webb
telescope and why is it replacing the
Hubble Space Telescope tell us about it
yeah well what astronomers hoped would
happen was that the Hubble telescope
would be operating more or less
flawlessly for its entire design
lifetime and then soon after the period
of about 20 2012 or so 2016 20 between
2012 to 2016 it will be replaced by a
far more powerful telescope and the
telescope designed to replace it would
have the light carrying capability of
about 9 Hubble Space Telescope's in a
single telescope and it would be able to
detect things that the hubble space
telescope couldn't detect because of
technical aspects of how that the Hubble
Space Telescope is primarily limited to
its ability to see in the optical
wavelengths that our eyes can see in but
to see things really far away you need
to go into infrared wavelengths and
that's where the James Webb Space
Telescope was supposed to shine no pun
intended
now it's gone over the budget limit do
you think that the delay makes sense
yeah I mean that's putting it mildly
that's like if you if you had a report
card limit of getting a C and you got an
F unfortunately the original budget was
only about a half a billion dollars or
so and the original duration of the
project was supposed to launch way well
before when it went on well currently
launch as I said and so this is a
project that's been going on since the
late 1990s and at the earliest it's all
went perfect
would launch by 2020 and the budgets
gone from 500 million dollars or so up
to about 10 billion dollars in estimated
equivalent currencies now that's not to
say that that it won't you know that the
delays weren't warranted in some sense
to repair aspects of the project but
unlike the Hubble telescope you might
recall that the Hubble telescope had its
share of delays too but some of those
were caused by things out of control of
the of the astronomers and the engineers
who are building the tall scope
namely the Challenger disaster that
delayed the launch of the Hubble
telescope by several years and then when
it was put in orbit and famously had its
in a blurry vision problem that needed
to be corrected by astronauts visiting
it in and as
prepare mission this telescope will be
launched so far away that the that no
space shuttle will be able to reach it
it'll be past the orbit of the moon so
you did touch on it a little bit in
terms of what it's capable of but tell
us why the James Webb telescope is
important for new discoveries about the
universe so when we look back in space
we're really looking back in time
because light travels at a very rapid
rate but nevertheless it travels at a
finite speed when you see something like
when you look at the moon you're not
seeing the moon as it is exactly now
when you see the Sun it's not exactly
now it's eight minutes ago so when you
look far back in space you're seeing
things as they were earlier in time and
when you look really far back in space
you're seeing things that are being
redshifted that they're expanding with
the expansion of the universe so if the
Sun were to be put at great distances
and subject to the expansion the
expansion that's taking place of space
itself the Sun would look a lot redder
than it does in fact most of its light
would be infrared and invisible to the
Hubble telescope or to our eyes so this
telescope has a very advanced camera
system the Webb telescope and now
allowed to detect not just the emission
of a single Sun but of enormous glock
conglomerations of galaxies and clusters
that are under the influence of dark
matter and dark energy that's what makes
it so special